bro i can suck my own dick
yeah i swear to god hold on i'll show
you right now
[Music]
i'm rocky jill davis and i'm here to
answer the internet today's episode of
ati is brought to you by roman more on
that at the end but first rocky dale
davis jr answers the internet would you
rather be the best looking dude in the
world or be able to read minds you know
i feel like i'm already like top five
right now
i look like channing tatum with down
syndrome tom brady's down syndrome yeah
i get thompson tom brady's brothers with
down syndrome you get tom brady before
the super bowl that's what you look like
feidelberg is ed sheeran with no number
one hits a couple podcasts though your
arms did look really great like you had
like like they do you dirty on the face
like yeah because i have like i have
love handles like it [ __ ] sucks it's
just so annoying my girlfriend grabbed
me about my love handles one time during
sex and i was like if you ever touch me
there again i will [ __ ] report you to
the law like these like i called my mom
and i was like like emotional support i
was i felt like a rape victim it was not
good because like if you take away this
it's like the only thing it's like i
have like i have like child birthing
hips like i had a huge like like about
32 in seemed like a 38 weights it's like
the [ __ ] worst dude and this [ __ ]
never goes away it's the worst would you
give up an inch of penis link for an
inch of height i'm already pretty tall
i'm gonna say no yeah yeah like six
threes like too good you know because
like six yeah cause like six four with
like a 12 inch dick is like a little bit
like odd you know so i'll say
you stop laughing over there okay
she's like i see your pants yeah no i
don't think i would on that one though
this is i just asked this question the
other day uh how many rats would it take
to overwhelm and kill you in a fight
well i i did i did raccoons the other
day because i was saying like squirrels
raccoons like if you'd rather fight 20
raccoons or 50 squirrels that what's
your answer so with how do how many rats
to kill you in a fight
that's a good [ __ ] question
realistically like probably 20 rats
could [ __ ] you up like think about it
realistically like 20 right because you
gotta think what are you gonna do grab
them you're gonna kick them they're
gonna [ __ ] grab on you dude and these
rats in nyc they're like jacked like vin
diesel some subway rats are coming at
you you're gonna grab one or two and
maybe throw they're coming right back at
you i mean wheeler like willard like was
he had little mouses and like if you
talk about nyc rats or like [ __ ]
field rats i actually think raccoons
would be easy because you can fight a
raccoon well if you grab it if you punch
a rat yeah like even if you like if you
hit a rat like what's it really going to
do it doesn't have enough body weight
you can kind of punch a raccoon but also
if you grab a raccoon my buddy dean he
used to uh he lives on a farm he said if
you grab a raccoons they were trying to
steal his hot dog one day so i swear to
god true story he had like six raccoons
come out and they're trying to grab his
hot dog and he grabbed them by the back
of the neck and they go limp like this
right here what do you do and so that's
the secret with raccoons i don't know
about within rice sea rats i don't know
like what he's like the mets won a game
or something like they like run over
i don't know how you defer them here
like what what are they into like hey
there's a gabagoose over there like yeah
dude you know i'm saying 20 20 can [ __ ]
me up would you rather be the world's
tallest man or the world's shortest man
i'm gonna say the world's shortest man
right because you drove tall that guy
like doesn't really do much like he's
like can barely walk around lord's
shortest man was vern troyer like he
like was one of the top lowest and that
guy was in [ __ ] he was like sucking
on titties all the time and stuff like
every picture of him he's like suck he's
like pissing he already pissed in that
celebrity house he lived in that one
house it would just piss you the whole
little thing yeah if you like would you
rather be the world's shortest man or
tallest man it's like dude kevin hart's
doing great
kevin hart's doing awesome he's doing
[ __ ] phenomenal and he has a huge
dick by the way for ten thousand would
you rather spend two days carrying
around a human-looking japanese robot
that you had to introduce to people as
your friend as your girlfriend yeah 100
i mean that's an easy one what about
what about if it's like
you're filming your first special and
it's like those two days you gotta bring
her backstage just bring her everywhere
everyone's your meeting is like you're
you're doing hollywood meetings yeah
that's what it's like this is my
girlfriend that's what whitney cummings
did like what are you talking about
and she got a lot more than 10 grand but
she still has that robot whitney's 100
[ __ ] it too i guarantee you [ __ ] yeah
i mean dude like you're walking a
japanese robot they'd be surprised what
it is in alabama but what was that
the mexican i mean it's like every
answer is gonna get me canceled you know
it's great would you rather live in a
world with only girls or a world with
only guys but you couldn't jerk off wait
so can i [ __ ] the wait hold on
yeah i mean that's i mean i don't know
like i feel like these answers are kind
of easy like it's like i'd live with the
dudes like what would you do [ __ ] the
dudes
i'm sorry but like
dude whatever like think about like the
dudes like think about like think about
the time we just had we did it was such
a fun time and think about like if my
girlfriend was there how much that would
have sucked you know people would have
been talking about you know pilot pete
from the bachelor like that [ __ ] suck
dude dude [ __ ] dudes is like on my
mind all the time like i see like
because dudes in my c they have like the
chunky butts you know because they're
constantly walking so much and do you
know like that like you know it's just
hitting think about [ __ ] guys purely
for the perspective of like when you
move right with your girlfriend she's
like i got i got the silverware and
you're like carrying a [ __ ] couch in
your back dude would you take a million
dollars to be one of the pickiest oh
pick it pick up man i'm [ __ ] trucking
uh would you take a million dollars to
be one of the picket people for the west
baptist church during a fallen soldier's
funeral again like
y'all know anne did y'all know the hand
i know you guys knew my mom man my my
grandfather is racist as hell right so
so with other day his alzheimer's has
almost cured his racism because he
forgot he was racist right
and so the other day we're at the house
he hasn't said racist [ __ ] like three
years man 96 okay so we're at the house
and i walk in i've been watching the
movie on hbo right and so he it's not
funny i usually have to turn it on fox
news for him but he doesn't get seized
and i go i go i go what are you doing
man he goes nothing watching the damn
queers trying to take the world from the
white man and i was like all right so
all right good to have you back grandpa
let's
talk about childhood memories while
you're here for a minute you know it's
like when dee dee and them their grandpa
was the nazi they didn't realize it they
watched the childhood tapes and they're
like okay
what is one thing that someone can say
that makes you immediately hate them um
i love call or daddy like i don't
oh [ __ ] when people talk about pepsi
pepsi is the worst i hate pepsi i got in
a bunch of trouble because i i said when
someone says like they said pepsi is
better than coke because coke said be
less white and it's like a big thing
like be less white at the company it's
like who cares i i said that i said the
ceo of coke could murder my entire
family and i would still choose it over
a pepsi and so then i get like a bunch
of hate and everybody's like you're a
white guilt you know piece of [ __ ] and
i'm like bro no i just don't like pepsi
and then i'm getting messages like
unfollowed unfollowed and then like i've
seen like a bunch like white night stuff
in the back not the one y'all think
either the one from where i'm from and
uh
white knight society and i'm like i
don't need you following me anyways i
bought a shirt and i'm like oh [ __ ] can
you take that back would you rather have
a tiny hot leprechaun you could [ __ ]
whenever or have a leprechaun's gold
worth a quarter of a million dollars i'm
gonna say i'm gonna take the money
because i have a girlfriend at the
moment we'll take the money and i'll let
her spend it on a christian louboutin as
she says shoes she wants but don't want
to work for um
she wants a bracelet you ever heard of
the cartier you ever heard of cartier
yeah right there dude there you go
that's tough [ __ ] right there bro y'all
pay a lot of barstool for her to know
that okay uh who would win in a fight 10
10 year olds or 100 hundred year olds i
would say 100 100 100 year olds but i'm
thinking also you got to think too a
hundred year old's gonna have like first
off they have like chlamydia right from
like all the homes so they're like
you're fighting a koala bear at that
point right like
if they bite you you may win now you
know but you're gone later right would
you rather your girlfriend get a
notification every time you watch porn
with a description or a notification of
where you are at all times a thousand
percent where you are at all times
bro
i can't explain i've gone on my reddit
before and i've looked at like what i've
typed in i'm chasing explain you can't
explain it yeah it's i'm just like no
it's okay i can't because it's like
illegal and um
when i was 15 years old i looked up i
googled 15 year old porn when i was 15.
right so like
and there was a website someone had set
up that said like the fbi is at your
house now i'm 15
i'm used to dial up internet in alabama
you know and i'm like oh my god they got
me dude you know like my girlfriend
looked at my porn list one time and uh
and it was just it was rough it was real
rough stuff and it's like like where
she's like do you want that to happen
and i'm like no yeah yeah
by the way my girlfriend met rogan
chappelle two weeks ago and didn't
mention my name one time she goes green
room she talks to chappelle for 10
[ __ ] minutes they talk about detroit
property i'm like hey [ __ ] did you
mention my name and she goes oh yeah i
said my boyfriend's a comedian i'm like
maybe like my boyfriend's a comedian
pretty funny get a little following rock
files another big deal you know didn't
say [ __ ] word to him or rogan and i
was like i don't i don't like you you
know and then she's like she's like well
i want the lupus i was like ass [ __ ]
chappelle for the limits instead [ __ ]
you know you want us a [ __ ] bad would
you rather have one giant dick for an
arm or have all your fingers be dicks
this is a question i've heard before and
this is a tough one honestly i'm gonna
say uh uh one giant dick for an arm but
i do have a question though do all your
fingers come individually or no
uh
yeah okay then that's tough man that's
where you complicated a little bit
because a giant dick for an arm is
amazing you know it's a tool yeah
you can do whatever you want with that
it makes like you can't do anything with
that
i think it's easy to take your fingers
what can you do with a giant digger [ __ ]
somebody you can't [ __ ] anybody with
that stick arms
dude imagine the press run you do though
like what are you gonna do with dick
fingers just like that you can [ __ ]
people yeah but that you can't you can't
like do normal [ __ ] you ever heard that
your dick's this link that's a really
tough one i would say one giant dick
because what do you do with fingers like
what are you gonna do with fingers for
dicks i mean then you can [ __ ] so you
can just get horny and use a regular ass
hand
because you can find your fingers
no your dick
also how are you going to masturbate
these by the way like what you gonna do
just be like [ __ ] sitting there yeah
like like clapping like a golf [ __ ]
clap
[Laughter]
fingers by the way bro i can suck my own
dick you can suck yeah i swear to god
hold on i'll show you right now oh yeah
yeah
you can't take them off that's fine man
okay oh no
not jeremy pippen
guys welcome to brookwood episode three
itunes spotify
[Laughter]
yeah bro
i've been discussing wrestling what
not a lot because my uncle's on top of
me
bam that's how you [ __ ] close it
right there my brother thank you man
that's going to crush you thank you so
much hilarious
i'm a big fan of this
thank you all so much i appreciate it
more than you know man big thank you to
rocky dale davis jr for coming through
now i know rocky he's a premature
ejaculator so i'm going to go ahead and
get him some roman swipes i'm going to
go to getroman.com answer and i'm going
to get a whole pack of swipes for just
five bucks and i'm going to give them to
my good friend rocky because i know he
can't last long in bed and if you've got
those same problems you buy the swipes
you open them up you wipe them on your
dick it desensitizes it but you can
still enjoy it even if you're having sex
with rocky dale davis jr go to
getroman.com answer to get your swipes
for just five likes
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon